[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour
bienvenue sur sensation en association
avec TV 78 aujourd'hui je suis avec
François Gansel celui qu'on appelle le
monsieur Montesson l'un des directeurs
du Fast 5000 bonjour bonjour merci de me
recevoir la prochaine édition du phase
100000 se déroulera le 10 juin à
Montesson quelle est l'histoire de
l'événement et quelles en sont les
objectifs alors c'est un événement qui a
lieu déjà depuis on attaque la troisième
année voilà il y a deux ans on a essayé
de mettre en place un peu bousculer les
l'image de de l'athlétisme en essayant
de mettre un meeting dethlé de très très
haut niveau et on est associant des
animations autour de manière à ce que
des gens passionnés d'athlés des fans
puissent voir des athlètes de très haut
niveau et à côté de ça voir des familles
venir découvrir un peu la clé en faisant
des animations l'idée c'est que les
spectateurs soient au plus près des
athlètes et sur le stade pour suivre les
performances donc c'est
de midi à 23 heures le 10 juin
effectivement à Montesson
donc les valeurs quelles sont les
valeurs que vous souhaitez transmettre à
travers cet événement alors les valeurs
en fait vraiment l'idée est venue de
avec mes deux compères directeurs du
meeting de Houilles Simon messager et
Sébastien sapaille de de monter un grand
événement sportif en essayant de réunir
les meilleurs athlètes internationaux
sur 5000 mètres
c'était un vrai pari surtout de les
faire venir jusqu'à Montesson et puis on
a eu la chance avec un partenaire un
équipementier cette année l'équipe
entier de Roger Federer de venir
d'arriver à regrouper sur dans un dans
un système de plusieurs meetings au
niveau international puisqu'il y a eu
déjà un meeting à Los Angeles un autre à
Londres qui a eu lieu ce samedi il y
aura donc Paris Montesson et un Vienne
il y a un Melbourne ou en fait dans ce
challenge de de meeting on essaie de
réunir tous les meilleurs athlètes
internationaux donc voilà c'est un peu
l'idée
alors en deux ans fast 5000 a su se
faire une popularité notamment donc
auprès des sportifs de haut niveau ils
sont d'ailleurs votre cible principale
pour cet événement mais sont-ils les
seuls à pouvoir y participer en d'autres
termes qui peut participer à phase 5000
alors effectivement c'est vraiment un
meeting international ou en tout cas de
niveau international puisqu'on attend
encore le
labellisation au niveau de la Fédération
internationale d'athlétisme mais
effectivement on a la cible le principal
c'était la tête de ligne de très haut
niveau et de les mettre dans les
conditions pour battre leur meilleure
performances et de se qualifier pour des
championnats du monde ou les Jeux
Olympiques donc ça l'objectif est réussi
l'objectif aussi c'était d'amener un
certain nombre de personnes du secteur
au niveau des clubs locaux pour pouvoir
y participer donc on met en place des
3000 mètres de niveau où effectivement
des athlètes de moins bon niveau peuvent
venir participer puis cette année la
grande nouveauté c'est qu'on y mêle les
enfants des écoles de la ville de
Montesson en ouverture de manière à ce
que effectivement on est une population
variée et que ces personnes là puisse se
retrouver sur la même piste d'athlétisme
mais dans les mêmes conditions
c'est-à-dire avec
des feux d'artifice de la musique
des beaux dossards de manière à ce
qu'ils soient ils aient un souvenir de
ce grand moment d'athlétisme en fait
alors homme comme femme peuvent
participer à ce meeting est-ce que c'est
parti de votre ADN de valoriser le sport
féminin alors absolument l'idée c'est
effectivement de d'arriver à regrouper
homme et femme pour ça d'ailleurs au
niveau des primes de de participation et
notamment les primes d'arrivée pour les
trois premiers hommes et les trois
premières femmes c'est exactement le
même le même montant qui est offert de
manière à ce que les femmes et les
hommes soient absolument soit vraiment
sur le même pied d'égalité évidemment
c'est un peu le le la difficulté au
niveau de la titise française il y a
moins de femmes de très haut niveau que
d'hommes donc on aura 9 séries hommes
international et cinq séries femmes mais
le but du jeu effectivement c'est
d'avoir le même nombre d'hommes et de
femmes bientôt sur sur ce meeting mais
voilà c'est l'intérêt c'est que homme
comme femme on est un
même niveau de d'exigence et de
performance en fait
pour aider les coureurs il y aura des
lièvres et des wave lights le long du
parcours concrètement qu'est-ce que
c'est à quoi ça sert alors l'idée
effectivement c'est d'offrir aux
athlètes suivant les séries puisque
chaque série aura une une un certain
niveau en fait on
engage en même temps des lièvres qui qui
emmènent les athlètes sur puisque c'est
un 5000 mètres au moins jusqu'au 3000
sur les bons tempo en fait de manière à
ce que effectivement c'est des athlètes
arrivent à faire la performance qu'il
souhaitait puisque c'est ça l'objectif
c'est qu'il battent leur record
personnel l'année dernière sur le sur
les meeting il y a eu plus de 60% de
meilleures performances réalisées par
les athlètes donc c'est ce qui viennent
chercher en fait ils viennent chercher
des conditions pour battre leur record
donc ça c'est vraiment le truc le plus
important et puis cette année la grande
nouveauté c'est les wave light les wave
lights c'est en fait un système lumineux
qui se situe au niveau de la corde de la
piste juste au premier couloir et qui en
fait suit les athlètes et qui donne le
tempo aussi pour les athlètes donc c'est
vraiment une une technologie qui est
vraiment
qui est couru pour les athlètes parce
que c'est vraiment une recherche de
performance ça permet de leur donner le
bon rythme pour aller chercher leur père
en fait c'est ça l'idée
alors vous avez vous avez parlé des
primes qui étaient donc équivalentes
pour les hommes et pour les femmes
est-ce que vous en dire plus qu'on va
gagner en fait les vainqueurs en quatre
victoires alors oui oui je peux je peux
vous dire ça c'est c'est marqué sur
notre site face 5000.fr le premier
touchera une prime de 6000 € le deuxième
4000 et le troisième 1000 euros alors
vous avez aussi parlé donc des citoyens
enfin qui peuvent assister à l'événement
selon vous pourquoi est-il intéressant
d'assister à phase 5000 alors l'intérêt
c'est effectivement c'est un peu ce que
je dis tout au début c'est à dire qu'en
fait il l'intéresse c'est d'avoir
d'être au contact des athlètes de très
très haut niveau voilà pour nommer un
certain il y a d'immigrésie et qui vient
qui est un des meilleurs athlètes
français sur sur 1500 mètres par exemple
on a Jimmy Wenders le Belge qui sera là
enfin des athlètes effectivement qu'on
ne voit pratiquement qu'à la télé ou
quelquefois sur des stades mais dans une
tribune là vous serez au bord de la
piste il y a vraiment un contact direct
donc c'est vraiment l'intérêt de pouvoir
venir à ce meeting et puis aussi c'est
qu'on y a mis autour autour de cette
manifestation sportive
des tas d'animation pour les enfants
pour les jeunes mais pour les grands
puisqu'il y aura des food truck il y
aura des Birk pour y passer l'après-midi
et passer un très bon moment entre potes
histoire de d'être tous ensemble des
animations type château gonflable mur
d'escalade etc pour que les enfants
aussi puissent participer il y a une un
système de garderie pour que les parents
sont un peu tranquilles et puis ça les
profiter de leur après-midi et laisser
leurs enfants c'est c'est vraiment il
faut que ce soit quelque chose de festif
on est associé cette année à la à la
fête de la jeunesse de la ville de
Montesson et ça va être un grand moment
je pense de réunion où on aura aussi
bien les fans les spécialistes de
d'athlète mais aussi des gens qui
veulent simplement passer un très très
bon moment sur un stade au mois de juin
à monter son
très bien et est-ce que vous avez déjà
des noms d'athlètes professionnels qui
participeront votre événement il y a du
blender ce qui sera là donc j'ai migré
on en a un certain nombre pour les pour
les plus les athlètes de très très haut
niveau il faut savoir que ça fonctionne
un peu comme ça les managers et les
entraîneurs
jusqu'à 15 jours une semaine donc là on
est encore un tout petit peu trop tôt
pour la confirmation des tops athlètes
niveau parce que effectivement ils
attendent en fonction d'une blessure en
fonction du d'un problème particulier
mais effectivement ce sera de niveau la
finale
la
série une en fait la finale de de ces
5000 mètres qui aura lieu aux alentours
de 21h30 le soir
ce sera de niveau olympique c'est-à-dire
que pour les athlètes pour les personnes
qui connaissent la clé les hommes c'est
aux alentours de 13 minutes les femmes
de 14 14 30 donc c'est c'est vraiment du
très très haut niveau c'est je pense que
on aura jamais vu autant d'athlètes de
ce niveau là sur une sur une piste
d'accle en France ça c'est évident et
sans vouloir trop m'avancer même au
niveau mondial on n'a jamais réuni
autant d'athlètes de ce niveau là
face 5000 se passe à Montesson pourquoi
alors c'est
d'abord parce que c'est une ville
passionnante passionnée et qui fait tout
pour le sport on est venu nous trouver
parce qu'on est des installations
exceptionnelles et puis l'avantage c'est
qu'on est aussi dans un dans un cadre je
dirais bucolique et campagnard
parce que en fait c'est un peu ce qu'on
veut garder au niveau de l'ADN du phase
5000 c'est-à-dire que on sort un petit
peu des meetings très
urbains et ce côté
ce côté campagne mais professionnel
c'est à dire qu'en fait l'idée c'est
effectivement de mettre tout les chances
du côté pour les athlètes pour qu'il
fasse les meilleures performances les
wave les lèvres le trait au niveau